tell me about from your perspective
whether typically companies go wrong in
keeping their staff so what are the
common frustrations pounds that you hear
from recruiters is it that they work for
a manager who is a proper micromanager
or doesn't Empower them don't feel
valued is it I haven't had the right
training where a company's falling short
you think one thing that comes to mind
and it's trust especially with this
whole work from home thing it's caused a
lot of politics in many companies often
because somebody maybe has not done a
very good job working from home so as a
result the whole team are not allowed to
work from home anymore and the people
are actually quite trustworthy and work
very autonomously get really frustrated
by that and I think as a manager one of
the best things that you can do is show
trust to your employees and make them
accountable and not watch them that old
school recruiting of like how many calls
you made today how many calls you made
today I don't think it works I don't and
like you get results maybe yes for a
certain amount of time looking at call
time and analyzing it but ultimately
showing them trust the results come out
for themselves and the best companies
are the ones are not hiring and firing
but they're the ones who coach to
understand that actually you know what
this role isn't for me and the person
makes the decision themselves instead of
on the firing line which creates fear
uncertainty and negativity in teams the
recruitment mentors podcast is proudly
sponsored by vincere and the
award-winning Source breaker